around the world 300 000 women and more
than a million newborns lose their lives
every year from complications of
pregnancy and childbirth
often in health facilities that don't
have electricity
turns out that 59 of health facilities
in low and middle income countries
are without reliable electricity or have
no electricity whatsoever
so midwives and doctors struggle to save
lives in near darkness
and we care solar is bringing solar
electricity to health facilities in need
to help health workers have the power to
save lives
and women and children to have safe
childbirth yeah i've had a number of
different chapters in my life
i originally thought i was going to be a
concert pianist and dancer
in college and then i had a medical
condition that required me to have
surgery and that got me very interested
in women's health care
so i became a pre-med student and ended
up becoming a doctor
so for years i was an obstetrician
gynecologist and i loved my job i loved
delivering babies and then when i was
about 40
i had a devastating setback i had a back
injury
that literally put an end to my clinical
career i had to stop delivering babies
stop
doing surgeries and for about a year
get physical rehabilitation so that i
could even sit
up for extended periods of time after a
year i was told i wouldn't be able to be
a clinician anymore
so i turned my attention to public
health i went to graduate school
in public health first getting my
master's in maternal child health and
then entering a phd program
and while i was there i was invited to
join a research project in northern
nigeria
that was studying why so many women die
in childbirth
at that time about half a million women
died every single year from
complications of pregnancy and
childbirth
which was so different than my own
experience as an obstetrician where i
saw
pregnancy and childbirth as a really
joyous event
so i joined this research project in
northern nigeria where i did
medical anthropology i basically sat
myself in a hospital watching doctors
and nurses as they conducted care
to try and understand some of the
factors contributing to these
terrible loss of life so i started
writing home to people about
the conditions that i was seeing
particularly to my husband
hal aronson who's a solar engineer and
he said look when you get back
maybe we can come up with a solution and
so when i returned to the states
he developed a solar electric system for
the hospital and over the next year the
maternal deaths dropped by 70 percent
the solar suitcase is a compact rugged
solar electric system that was designed
specifically for maternal health care
it includes medical surgical lights
rechargeable head lamps
medical devices such as a fetal heart
rate monitor and an infrared thermometer
as well as 12 volt dc charging for
phones and other devices
and we deliver these to remote health
centers that may have no electricity or
unreliable electricity
and with the solar suitcase midwives and
doctors are able to provide
immediate and appropriate medical care
so it enables health workers to have
bright light and emergency communication
so that no matter where they are
they can provide immediate and
appropriate medical care for women in
need
what was once viewed as the most
devastating setback to my career
ended up opening the door to probably
even a more exciting career in some ways
and you know i loved actually delivering
babies i loved working with patients
one-on-one but now i know i'm touching
literally millions of lives
through the work of my team and through
our organization
and you know even though i hadn't ever
imagined that i'd have a career like
this
i think particularly after 50 it's
really wonderful to say
how can i touch the world there's so
many problems in the world
that need all sorts of skills and
resources in order to solve them
and so in a way i feel like many
different parts of my life brought me to
this moment that i'm able to step
up and really rise to the challenge of
trying to solve a global problem
you